[Music]
the colonization of space has always
been a dream of ours for some time i
mean think about it all the major sci-fi
movies are based on us exploring the
stars star wars star trek dune you name
it and while we might be light years
away from that level of space
exploration we have always figured that
mars would be the first step or at least
we thought so while mars is typically
the first planet most think of when it
comes to colonization there is another
equally if not better candidate in our
very own solar system saturn's moon
titan now while there is no known planet
with the same environmental complexities
and capabilities as earth we have found
a few that are just maybe close enough
mars for example it holds the
resemblance of a once lush and green
planet with a massive ocean now it's
mostly desert and rock with some ice
caps but while most planets seem too old
for us to inhabit as is the case with
mars titan may be the first we've
discovered that is too young
this terrifying new discovery on titan
changes everything
titan
saturn's moon titan
recently we found something very strange
in the orange clouds something so
bizarre and unique that it got nasa
involved with the billions of stars in
the universe nasa typically gets
involved in most discoveries that is
unless it's life-altering as the case
with titan this new discovery has got
nasa plotting a brand new mission with
the sole purpose of investigating this
mystery further what could this thing be
why is it so important and why did we
only just recently discover it all
questions that i'm sure you want
answered but first we need a quick
rundown on this incredible moon titan so
real quick some fun facts about titan
this great moon is tidally locked to its
home planet saturn which is 759
thousand miles away from it it has a
radius of about 1600 miles which is
considered to be fairly big by moon
standards it takes titan 15 days and 22
hours to make a full orbit around saturn
and 29 earth years to make a complete
orbit around the sun and last but
certainly not least it has the very rare
feature of an atmosphere the thick
atmosphere of titan is four times that
of earth's but also the atmospheric
pressure is about 60 percent greater for
your information in comparison our solar
system is home to 150 moons of those 150
only four of them have an atmosphere
titan being one of those four you see
titan is the second largest moon in our
solar system and the largest moon that
belongs to saturn more so titan is the
only place in the solar system other
than the planet earth that has liquids
on its surface the weather cycle there
is very similar to ours except it rains
frozen liquid methane and ethane because
of its striking resemblance to earth
titan could be the best place for human
colonization in fact the conditions on
titan are good enough for us to build a
long-term self-sustaining human
settlement because of its atmospheric
pressure it would feel equivalent to
swimming 50 feet underwater it sounds
scary i know but this would mean that
humans wouldn't need to wear bulk
pressurized suits to walk around on the
surface and with the thick atmosphere
deadly radiation from the sun or space
wouldn't be able to reach us in layman's
terms it means that titan is a safe
environment for humans the people of
titan would be able to bounce around
great distances because of titan's low
gravity considering it only has 14
percent of earth's gravity if you wanted
to glue some wings and feathers on
yourself you could literally fly around
under your own power sounds like
paradise right well not exactly titan is
very very cold on average the moon sits
about 886 million miles away from the
sun with a surface temperature of minus
290 degrees while you may not need a
pressurized suit you would need to
bundle up a lot any sunlight that would
reach you would give you just about as
much warmth as a sunset on earth would
so
none on top of all that you would need
to wear a respirator to breathe or your
lungs would freeze instantly
c3h2
now back to the question at hand what
was that terrifying discovery that put
titan under the microscope well a team
of scientists identified a molecule
called cyclopropeneldine or c3h2 in
titan's atmosphere this is big news
because this molecule has never been
detected anywhere else except in deep
space discovered using the atacama large
millimeter array alma alma is made of 66
radio antennas that all work together
creating a single giant telescope alma
uses techniques known as interferometry
basically all the antennas are pointed
at the same point in the sky the
antennas pick up a signal from the
target in the universe and join forces
to analyze the signal by combining radio
waves from the antennas using a
supercomputer with this researchers can
obtain extremely high precision images
this is not an easy feat synchronization
between all antennas has to be perfect
with only a millionth of a million
margin for error with this incredible
technology researchers found c3h2 a
strange organic molecule that doesn't
exist terrestrially on earth and can
only be seen in a laboratory
c3h2 was first discovered in clouds of
gas and dust throughout the milky way
this includes the taurus molecular cloud
what makes this molecule even more
amazing is that it may be a precursor to
more complex compounds it could form or
even feed possible life on titan much
like the organic molecules that formed
life on earth three and a half billion
years ago c3h2 is the only other cycle
or closed loop molecule beside benzene
to have been found in titan's atmosphere
close loop molecules like it are
important because they form the backbone
rings for the nuclear bases of dna and
rna things that are critical compounds
for life's functions while c3h2 is not
known to be used in any modern day
biological reactions nasa says the
molecule could be an indicator for life
since something has to be generating an
unstable molecule if there is life on
titan it would be incredibly different
from the water-based life forms we know
the mission
so the mission nasa was so intrigued by
this new discovery on titan that it
wants to study the moon in more detail
in 2019 nasa announced the dragonfly
mission with a planned launch in 2027
after its launch it would take nine
years for it to reach titan and arrive
in 2036 the estimated cost of the
mission is a staggering 1 billion
dollars but this is because the
dragonfly is a very unique spacecraft
design it is much like a large
quadcopter drone it has two rotors on
each end of the spacecraft's four
corners hence the name dragonfly
when it finally arrives on titan in the
year 2036 it will need to travel to
different areas for study in contrast to
most probes nasa has made in the past
they have decided to take advantage of
the moon's low gravity and have the
vehicle flying around this time rather
than roving the surface the cool thing
is that this will be the first time nasa
flies a multi-rotated spacecraft for
science equipped with a radioisotope
thermoelectric generator the dragonfly
will run on the heat from the decaying
plutonium-238 battery turning it into
electricity
this nuclear battery means that
dragonfly can theoretically operate on
titan for decades also with its
impressive maneuverability it can always
be moved to keep dragonfly on the side
of the planet closest to earth for
optimum communication which already
takes about 70 to 90 minutes each way
with a projected mission of 2.7 years
dragonfly will take advantage of the
dense atmosphere protecting it from
harsh rays and radiations flying to many
different locations unhindered its
mission is to collect and examine
surface material for chemistry
experiments it'll also check the planet
to see if it's possible for humans to
colonize one day
since the building blocks of life are on
titan dragonfly will also study how far
pre-life chemistry has progressed to get
a better understanding of how life
evolved on our own planet this mission
to titan could finally give us the
definitive answer to how life evolved
from organic molecules the discoveries
on titan can be revolutionary and just
may change everything we know about life
now all that's left is to build the
spacecraft and prepare for the
unexpected even if we don't find what
we're looking for on titan it will
provide us with more data on the moon
that we did not know before that's what
science is right a giant book of black
pages and we as scientists trying to
fill it with all the answers who knows
maybe sometime soon we'll start a
chapter on the science of alien life
what about you what do you think we'll
find on titan let us know in the comment
section below till next time